let's talk about James Comey and his
testimony now as you know James Comey
was fired as FBI director he was
scheduled to testify today Thursday as
FBI as current FBI director that's been
canceled which means that the firing of
James Comey has already had an immediate
impact on the investigation into Trump
Russia however we have now learned that
James Comey has been asked to testify as
a private citizen just a day after being
fired by Donald Trump reports said that
the Senate intelligence committees
Chairman Richard Burr a Republican and
Democratic ranking member Mark Warner
said that they had asked mr. Comey
to appear before the committee next
Tuesday as a private citizen it wasn't
immediately clear whether Comey would or
wouldn't accept the invitation whether
this would be open or closed here's Mark
Warner explaining what's going on but
chairman Burr and I sent out a joint
request to former director Comey to
appear before Senate Intel next Tuesday
May 16th we've not heard that we just
sent out the letter this morning he was
you know he was scheduled to testify
before the committee tomorrow along with
all the other heads of the intelligence
community yeah and so my hope is that
he'll take advantage of this opportunity
I don't know whether James Comey will or
will not testify next week but I damn
well hope that he has a good security
detail in place the last thing we need
Pat is James Comey accidentally stabbing
himself in the back ten times and then
poisoning himself right that could
possibly happen
I mean if James Comey does testify I
think he would conduct himself
professionally it's not he would be
throwing bombshells left and right yeah
part of that is because I'm sure he
would have to keep some things
confidential but also because he just
wouldn't see that as the right thing to
do but if there were things that he was
on the fence on when it comes to
speaking about those topics and I think
he would be more likely to just let them
go
that's my sense I mean either way Comey
can tell his story and I'm guessing that
the Trump administration what I mean is
as FBI director or as former FBI
director Comey can talk to people right
my thought would be the Trump
administration calculated that having
Comey telling the story
as a disgruntled outsider is not as bad
as having him do it as the sitting FBI
director he's also easier to write off
as this is just a disgruntled guy but
there is a difference between testifying
as a private citizen and former FBI
director then as the current FBI
director number one as a former FBI
director he would no longer have access
to the up-to-the-minute knowledge of
what the FBI has right he would also be
more free to give personal opinions as
Pat is pointing out it doesn't mean he's
going to violate confidentiality or
spill secret information but at least
when asked what's your personal
characterization of this he would no
longer need to hide behind as FBI
director it would be inappropriate for
me to give my personal opinion he could
just give it and also I don't think his
career is going to go much further than
where he's been at I mean it's not like
he's going to be Attorney General when
the next administration comes around so
it's like he has nothing to lose in
terms of calculations though Trump
probably also calculated or you would
imagine although how much Trump
calculates is anyone's guess you would
imagine that Trump knew there would be
some uproar over firing Comey but that
the uproar over firing Comey would be
not as bad as the uproar over whatever
come--and his FBI investigation were
getting close to how Donald Trump has
dug himself such a huge hole with such
tiny hands is a mystery that I don't
know that we're going to solve anytime
soon
I wonder if Trump legitimately thought
that maybe firing Comey would prevent
him from playing any further part in the
investigation
I can imagine Trump seeing that now
James Comey might testify anyway and
asking his aides how is it possible I
fired the guy it doesn't seem like Trump
thought that this would have the effect
that it's had because maybe in his mind
he thought James Comey is disliked by
both Democrats and Republicans but no
one became but respected by both as well
in other ways and that's where I think
the backfire came we're going to follow
it we'll see what happens next Tuesday
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman follow the
show on twitter at david pakman show and
follow me on instagram at david pakman
today's program is sponsored in part by
taga dab the hosting specialists if
you've been listening to or watching the
David Pakman show for any length of time
you know we've had
what I would consider cataclysmic issues
with the hosting of our website over
time and for me it's really not just
about the hardware that's offered even
though tag a dab does offer cloud server
solutions Virtual Private servers
dedicated servers colocation services
etc it's really about the advice and the
customer service and at tag a DAB which
is rated nine point seven out of ten on
Trustpilot
at tag a dab they're hosting experts and
specialists are also there customer
support team okay so you're actually
getting support and advice from the
experts and I if you've ever had a
problem with website hosting you know
how important that is taga dab is based
in the UK but is available to our
viewers and listeners all over the world
and you can get a ten British pound
credit towards any new cloud server
account by going to signup tag adapt
calm /td PS that is signup dot ta ga da
b.com /t d PS check it out